you see what YouTube is with me yeah you
look like mr. t is amazing when I show
you what I'm about to show you'll
understand why I have to make sure I'm
secure at all times hey hey how you
doing you
all right I'm 2 Chainz Jason nice nice
to meet you Jason how you doing today
good I wanted to show you some of those
items will be make over here I see
Beverly Hills own I know it's expensive
no no it's quality quality over quantity
exactly
we specialize in my custom bespoke
pieces for some of the world's biggest
celebrities and powerful royalty members
and we do things that people are just
kind of scared to do like Diamond bowtie
one of the only diamond bowties you'll
see but at least it gives you a
different kind of look a different kind
of flavor when you go on that red carpet
event how much is it something like this
you're looking at around $10,000 we
could maybe step it up a bit and you
could do something like this which is a
diamond Bible pendant
well we take it a step further than that
because we include every page of the
Bible stop something like that you're
looking at about 15,000 this is not
thank you we have you know diamond
engagement rings like this that goes
upwards of $100,000 you ever thought
about putting it in a martini martini on
the rocks
I'll do it I'm gonna show you the
world's most expensive diamond shoes
ever created damn his only shoes I was
on his shoes Nick Cannon came to me and
said I wouldn't make a statement I want
to go on the finale of America's Got
Talent and I want to shock the world
with the most expensive shoes but he
took it a step further and said you know
what we're gonna get the shoes we're
gonna make the shoes he purchased the
shoes for two million dollars [ __ ] Nick
and Nick is a smart guy you guys got
seven shows on TV at the same time so I
really admire him but what we're doing
we're touring the shoes all around the
world and we're eventually going to
auction them off for charity Justin do
you mind open this roast please you got
some big-ass hand
so here we have it you have 340 carats
over 18,000 stones set that means nine
thousand per shoe it took nearly one
year to make the issues what makes these
shoes so difficult they were built on a
Tom Ford platform they're all movable
bendable so you can actually wear them
now you're not gonna win a race in these
you can't tap dance in these right but
you could definitely make a statement
when you walk on that red carpet and
these are Rio dime he's a real time baby
this is that's probably another about 15
pounds I just feel like you were these
shoes you would have really wear much
what if you're walking in with those
shoes you don't have to worry about
anything else that you wear shorts
exactly this shoe makes a statement in
itself you can wear a swimming trunk
really cause can't nobody say [ __ ] about
you because you have more two million
outlet shoes and he's gonna sell them to
give it a chair right that's joke okay
we're gonna wait one more year we're
gonna tour it all over the world it's
gonna stop at different museums and
eventually we're gonna sell it really
broom yeah I've definitely been blessed
a baby see two million but to be able to
see to meeting all in one pair shoes
yeah very incredible I thought I had
some pretty wild thoughts but apparently
Nick Cannon isn't much of a better
rapper than ya so we back the bling
episode not Jason two million dollars
for some time for shoes then [ __ ] you
gotta have diamonds on the bottom in the
sole they have to come with socks
diamond socks like Michael Jackson wore
and I'm still not gonna buy them for to
me that's just me